So let's look at the better implementation of
sequential consistency in which a core can reorder loads.
But this can lead to violations of sequential
consistency. So it has to also detect when sequential
consistency may be violated, and fix things. This
is, of course, easy to say but how do
we really do that? So let's at the program where there is a load to A, and
then sometime later, but not too much later, a load from B. So we need to make
this execute in order, if doing other wise
will violate sequential consistency. But we want to really execute
them out of order, if there is no
potential for sequential consistency violation. So let's look at
what happens in the reorder buffer of a
processor that tries to execute this. The reorder buffer
keeps instructions in program order. So the
first load will be known to come ahead
of the second load. Now, if we actually
do this access first and this second, then
there is no potential for violating sequential
consistency, because we are actually doing whatever the
simple implementation will do anyway. So the sequential
consistency violation can occur when we first do
load B, in our real execution order.
And later, for example, because the computation for
address of A has been delayed, we do load of A. Now the important thing to
note is that this is not necessarily a
violation of sequential consistency. If nobody writes either
B or A during this time, then the B here and the A here will be
the same as if we re-ordered them back
to their original program order. So we are
getting the same value of B no matter
where we load it. If nobody writes anything.
In fact for this to actually be a
violation of sequential consistency, like we can actually
get a different value for B then we
could in sequential consistency. What has to happen
is that there is at least one store to
B. Between the time we actually read B and
the time when we should have read B according
to sequential consistency. Why? Well because if we don't have
the store here, then the value we read here
is the same as the value that we would have
read here, where it would be okay to read
B. So now you can see how we can detect
violations of sequential consistency. When we read
something ahead of program order, we need to
start monitoring the coherence traffic produced by other
processors. So, if we se such a store,
then this load and anything that it fed the data to, must be replayed. Note that
this load, is repayable, because in the rub
is here, we're assuming that this low still
hasn't happened. Which means that the commit point
for the ROB is somewhere here or maybe
at the low here but definitely the load from B has not been committed so we
are capable of replaying it. In the worst case we can just cancel this load and
anything that follows and just refresh those instructions.
So we know how to undue the damage here.
But in order to detect the violation now we have to basically anything that we
load out of order, we need to monitor
coherence traffic until that load becomes in order.